mechanical clocks with every single
detail crafted by hand 2500 hours to
make a hat of gold threads jewelry made
of a thousand hand knitted nylon bubbles
an 18th century crown studded with
priceless gems chandeliers made of LED
lamps and dandelions valuable exclusive
and opulent objects they take time and
space to make pure luxury but the
Victoria and Albert Museum in London
wants to know what is luxury we have
chosen a question and feel that it's
necessary to start a new debate again to
start thinking about luxury and to kind
of open it up from discourse that we
feel has been honed in and has been very
limited just focusing on the luxury
industry brands etc worldwide luxury is
often associated with costs expensive
clothes yachts big villas and pricey
cars are often high up on people's wish
lists
yet luxury means something different to
everyone it's something very personal
luxury is well being able to the
selvages and buy whatever I like freedom
I suppose not sure he's food no cool
this is so much luxury is like nice
things you know like things that you
they just add to life you know no need
of it like thank you oh yeah I can have
all the things that are important for me
for example that my family is healthy
with all the stress we have the day long
you know just time this is the biggest
luxury in Western industrialized
countries luxury often means having time
to enjoy a stroll or spending time with
friends a luxurious lifestyle also
includes rest and relaxation good health
and nutrition and being globally
connected Jonathan fares researches
luxury at the University of Southampton
and is the publisher of the journal
luxury which takes a critical look at
the subject the term luxury changes
constantly what's rare is considered
precious we look at the 19th century the
idea of indoor private sanitation at one
point was an extreme luxury where is now
in the West it it's a social necessity
it's you know it's a legal requirement
and so we understand chronologically
that luxury has its own kind of time
scales but where those time scales are
being experienced I think halters so in
the West it moves quite rapidly in other
countries obviously the the processes of
something emerging as a luxury is much
much slower so things we need to live to
survive like clean air are to this day
luxury goods in some emerging in
developing countries as our clean water
education and food back to the Victoria
and Albert Museum what is luxury the
exhibition dares to take a glimpse into
the future
a DNA vending machine installation warns
about the loss of privacy which could
become a luxury good rare earths will
get more expensive natural resources are
drying up plastic furniture could become
a luxury good because oil is needed to
produce plastic the definition luxury
will be influenced by changes in society
and I think at the moment we are in
earlier in a moment where it's a
universally applied term so much so that
it is beginning to be emptied out of its
meaning having said that I am NOT saying
that it will disappear completely and I
think it might well reimagine the future
and have quite a different meaning
whether that's as I say something to do
with hats abstinence something to do
with less having time for yourself the
luxury of the future these items reflect
that utopia a pen without ink a compass
without a needle and a watch without
hands